all right speaking of white supremacy
the speaking of white genocide so a A&E
was getting ready to do an entire
documentary series on the KKK and the
title of it I believe was going to be
escaping the KKK so they weren't gonna
do this and show any favorable light to
the Klan but a part of this showed
required that they pay Klansmen and once
that became known there was a big
protest there were boycotts there were
all type of campaigns to pull this show
and essentially that's what happened so
Annie they stated their goals was their
goal was always with the series was
always to expose and combat racism and
hatred in all of its forms
well here's the thing Pat and maybe you
can help me with this the problem is is
that while you may be trying to shine a
negative light on the Klan elevating the
Klan to this national level once again
obviously you're gonna have the opposite
effect where people look at it with
endearment
yeah I mean there's plenty of shows like
this this whole idea has been played out
plenty of times before
and I don't usually take up too much of
an issue with it except for the fact
that they're gonna be paying these
people a snap it's not just the reality
TV show these are gonna be you know
people on their payroll and I can see
why that's facing a lot of backlash now
you know absolutely like it's the it's
the normalization its profiting off a
bigotry number one right so that's
nothing new where you have Fox News
there's plenty of opportunity to prop it
off a bigotry these of the Fox News it's
like the clickbait of TV it's exactly
that's exactly what the hell it is it's
the clickbait of TV but you also
normalize it right we're in this stage
where you can have people like Richard
Spencer who is the the leader of the new
alt-right movement who gets all this
airtime because he's the dapper
quote-unquote dapper neo-nazi and we
have all of these interviews taking
place all of these these these these
profiles by major media outlets so you
get this normalization affect not only
the normalization of bigotry but also
the profiting off of bigotry I mean I
don't think this was a good idea to
begin with
right so the fact that it's happened to
be pulled at this
is it's really should have been expected
like who's who's running production in
some of these places like did you not
see this coming
right the public shouldn't have to find
out about this and that's the reason why
you decide to pull the show exactly it
that should be part of your business
ethics at the first place which takes me
to the next layer right so there's
obviously being some research done I
don't think any show ever comes on
without there being some market research
there's obviously some interest in these
Nazi neo-nazi Klan bigoted elements of
America which is why you see all of
these profiles happening all of this new
emphasis and I don't know if it's only
because of Trump but I think it's been
helped by Trump so what do you do what
do you do when a portion of America
wants this type of programming and you
have the other half of America or I
don't know what percentage which you
have a rest of America who's saying hell
no Warby Parker is offering a free five
day home Tryon to give you the
opportunity to check out their glasses I
personally wear Warby Parker glasses
when I'm not wearing my contact lenses
and I also started with one of these
free at home try ons of five pairs of
glasses you can get your free home try
on and support the david pakman show at
Warby Parker trialed dot-com slash TDP s
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like $300 for prescription glasses high
which is just insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP
yes it costs nothing